foreign
[Music]
Medieval Europe where unbathed
sword-wielding Knights eat rotten meat
thought the Earth was flat defended
chastity belt wearing maidens and
tortured their foes with grisly gadgets
it
if this is more fiction than fact
so where do all the myths about the
Middle Ages come
the Middle Ages refers to a 1 000 year
time span stretching from the fall of
Rome in the 5th Century to the Italian
Renaissance in the 15th
though it's been applied to other parts
of the world the term traditionally
refers specifically to Europe one
misconception is that medieval people
were all ignorant and uneducated for
example a 19th century biography of
Christopher Columbus incorrectly
purported that medieval Europeans
thought the Earth was flat sure many
medieval Scholars describe the Earth as
the center of the universe but there
wasn't much debate as to its shape a
popular 13th century text was literally
called on the sphere of the world and
literacy rates gradually increased
during the Middle Ages alongside the
establishment of monasteries convents
and universities ancient knowledge was
also not lost Greek and Roman texts
continued to be studied the idea that
medieval people ate rotten meat and used
spices to cover the taste was
popularized in the 1930s by a British
book
it misinterpreted one medieval recipe
and used the existence of laws barring
the sale of putrid meat as evidence it
was regularly consumed in fact medieval
Europeans avoided rancid foods and had
methods for safely preserving Meats like
curing them with salt
spices were popular but they were
oftentimes pricier than meat itself so
if someone could afford them they could
also buy unspoiled food
meanwhile the 19th century French
historian Jules Michele referred to the
Middle Ages as a thousand years without
a bath but even small towns boasted
well-used public bath houses people
lathered up with soaps made of things
like animal fat Ash and scented herbs
and they used mouthwash teeth scrubbing
cloths with pastes and powders and
spices and herbs for fresh smelling
breath
so how about medieval torture devices in
1990s a collection of allegedly terrible
relics of a semi-barous age when on tour
among them the Iron Maiden which
fascinated viewers with its Spike doors
but it was fabricated possibly just
decades before and there's no indication
iron maidens actually existed in the
Middle Ages the pair of Anguish
meanwhile did exist but probably later
on and it couldn't have been used for
torture it may have just been a shoe
stretcher indeed many ostensibly
medieval torture devices are far more
recent inventions medieval legal
proceedings were overall less gruesome
than these gadgets suggest they included
fines imprisonment public humiliation
and certain forms of corporal punishment
torture and executions did happen but
especially violent punishments like
drawing and quartering were generally
reserved for crimes like high treason
surely chastity belts were real though
right probably not they were first
mentioned by a 15th century German
engineer likely ingest alongside fart
jokes and a device for invisibility
from there they became popular subjects
of satire that were later mistaken for
medieval reality
ideas about the Middle Ages have varied
depending on the interests of those in
later times the term along with the
pejorative Dark Ages was popularized
during the 15th and 16th Centuries by
Scholars biased toward the classical and
modern periods that came before and
after and as Enlightenment thinkers
celebrated their dedication to reason
they depicted medieval people as
superstitious and irrational
in the 19th century some romantic
European nationalist thinkers well
romanticized the Middle Ages they
described isolated white Christian
societies emphasizing narratives of
chivalry and wonder but Knights played
minimal roles in medieval warfare and
the Middle Ages saw large-scale
interactions ideas flowed into Europe
along Byzantine Muslim and Mongol trade
routes and Merchants intellectuals and
diplomats of diverse Origins visited
medieval European cities
the biggest myth may be that the
Millennium of the Middle Ages amounts to
one distinct cohesive period of European
history at all originally defined less
by what they were than what they weren't
the Middle Ages became a ground for
dueling ideas fueling more fantasy than
fact
[Music]
it's full of Legends learn about the
imaginary King who influenced real world
politics for over 400 years with this
video or dig into the legend of King
Arthur his Knights of the Round Table
and their quest for the Holy Grail to
find out if any of it was actually real
with this one